the list of arrested reads like the
who's who of Hong Kong's Democratic
Movement among them are present and
former legislative councillors prominent
activists and the man known as the
father of democracy in Hong Kong 81 year
old Martin Lee is one of the architects
of the basic law the city's mini
Constitution which essentially
safeguards the territory's autonomy he
had stepped away from the political
spotlight in recent years but was vocal
about his support for the protests last
year I have no regrets
for what I have done I feel proud to
walk the path of democracy these are
standing young protesters it's the
second time this year businessman and
media tycoon Jimmy Lai has been arrested
they have been arrested on suspicion of
organising and taking part in illegal
assembly the government has released a
statement saying the arrests were made
based on evidence and were in accordance
to the law the arrests come after week
of turmoil in the Legislative Council
pro-beijing members hustled with the
opposition Democrats for control of the
weekly meeting agenda in an unusual move
China's representative office in Hong
Kong waded in to denounce the
pro-democracy group the Beijing liaison
office monitors development in Hong Kong
and reports back to the Chinese
government but for the first time it
stated it has the right to supervise
local affairs and is exempt from a
clause in the Constitution which
restricts interference from any
department directly under Beijing's
control
that's provoking renewed fears amongst
democracy supporters already alarmed at
China's tightening grip on Hong Kong
since last June more than 7,000 people
have been arrested for their involvement
in the protests many are charged with
rioting which carries a maximum prison
sentence of 10 years this year there has
been a lull in the protests mostly due
to the corona virus pandemic the
government has banned all gatherings of
more than 4 people to enforce social
distancing but protesters and democracy
activists say government leaders are
making the most of a distracted public
along with trying to wipe out the virus
wiping out any dissent is the aim - they
say the Big Apple and al Jazeera Hong
Kong